the most effective thing you can do to
have more fun is to focus on its
ingredients by which I mean do
everything you can to fill your life
with more moments of playfulness
connection and flow so by playfulness I
just mean having a light-hearted
attitude when we have fun our guard is
down and we're not taking ourselves too
seriously connection refers to the
feeling of having a special shared
experience and then flow is the state
where we are so engaged and focused on
whatever we're doing that we can even
lose track of time so to start with
reduced distractions in order to
increase flow anything that distracts
you is going to kick you out of flow and
prevent you from having fun my second
suggestion is to increase Connection by
interacting more with other human beings
in real life you might be amazed by how
good just one little moment of
connection can make you feel and if you
do find someone to connect with maybe
ask them to join you and try on my third
suggestion which is to increase
playfulness by finding opportunities to
Rebel I'm talking about finding ways to
break the rules of responsible adulthood
and give yourself permission
to get a kick out of your own life